hallo herzlich willkommen ich bin heute
nicht in meiner küche ich will auch
nicht zu hause und auch nicht in
waghäusel
ich bin nämlich in frankfurt auf einer
sehr großen messe und weist es die
ambiente ich glaube sogar dass es
weltweit vielleicht die größte haushalts
und lifestylemesse die es überhaupt gibt
und ich bin heute hier denn ich habe ja
an den online shop und es wäre ja auch
dieses jahr im sommer meinen stationen
shop in baar kreis eröffnet und will
jetzt eben alles so machen den shop
haben die gehen eben alle auf messen und
suchen sich dann neue produkte aus denn
man will ja immer wieder wissen was
gibt's neues oder was gibt es für tools
sich noch nicht hatte
deswegen bin ich heute hier und möchte
euch einfach mal zeigen was es hier
alles gibt wurde alles kann ich nichts
sagen weil es echt ne riesen messe ist
hier geht es glaube ich elf hallen
gestern bei turnieren auf eine einzige
halle geschafft in ungefähr acht stunden
und ich würde ich jetzt einfach mal
sagen ich gehe jetzt los nehme ich mit
und zeigt euch einfach mal für die
highlights auf der messe die ich ebenso
finden kann folgt mir einfach
ich glaube hier bin ich richtig diese
freien raum statt
er hat nur quatsch im kopf
ich stehe jetzt hier wieder schönsten
stand auf der ganzen messe denn ich bin
wieder bei marx beim einen pinkfarbenen
küchenutensilien bei marc koch junge ist
mein eigentlicher kopf rum aber noch
viel mehr gern wir haben so viel mit
luthers der rallye stand können wir
haben extra dichten sie hier meine
lieblingsfarbe einmal alles auf gehört
ein foto
ja also der mag für manche kennen ja die
videos von früher nur apps denmark haben
wir mal kennengelernt
ach so ist er ein genie erzählt wie wir
zusammen gekommen sind und zwar hat der
seine schwägerin und so praktisch
vermittelt eine reihe guter
ganz genau dann haben wir sie euch mal
angeschrieben
der kontakt kam es aber raus dass die in
der nähe wohne wo der hat früher gewohnt
hat das auch schwabe
na ja sage nichts dazu na ja mal was
neues
du hast ja schon relativ viel haben neue
sachen
zwar haben wir einmal sein seien zum
beispiel gebaut und getreu unserem motto
das wir einfach ein super qualität bauen
ist es komplett einmal aus edelstahl
gebaut und silikon überzogen und auch
damit kannst du natürlich wieder in
heiße töpfe reihen bestimmt solche seien
720 viele geräte haben die bänder wir
haben die saucen löffel haben die
schöpfer die gewürzmühlen die du ja auch
schon hast schau mal was wir heute
speziell für den valentinstag und
natürlich den geburtstag meiner frau den
habe ich nicht vergessen die hand rät
markus stein und ich muss arbeiten
eine spiegel iphone wenn du spiegeleier
machst beziehungsweise pfannkuchen
machst oder rösti machst kriegst du das
einfach in die pfanne rhein gibt es den
teig sozusagen die masse oben rein geht
es ganz normal aus und hast dann diese
hedgefonds
es läuft geschossen das heißt also dein
mann mandy dann morgens immer das
frühstück ans bett bringt dann kann dir
quasi mit dem spiegel ein schon sagen
ich hatte schon den moral geniale
erfindung und zwar haben wir ja die koch
blumen damit sind wir quasi berühmt
geworden das haben wir einen radweg
gebaut
dieser artikel hat eine ganz
interessante sache mal ein schauer ich
habe mir zwar ist es interessante an
diesem deckel dass der ein automatik
ventil hat das heißt normalerweise
bremst du ja kein fleisch ohne deckel
hast du alles voller fetzer in diesen
becken nimmst du und er misst die
temperatur und sobald er über 80 grad
ist öffnet dieses ventil automatisch die
feuchte luft geht raus mein rad cross
ich habe trotzdem keine fettspritzer auf
dem herd
es funktioniert wie es interessante ist
wird wahrscheinlich den leuten zu hause
aus zu gehen man hat ja wahnsinnig viele
deckel im schrank dieser decke geht auf
22 er geht auf 24 auf 26 28 cm lässt du
hast nachher einen deckel
ja der markt immer coole sache zu recht
genau warum warum wollten wir monatlich
mitnehmen
das ich haben wir nicht warten im
nächsten video ich glaube der markt
möchte einfach an die kamera übernehme
ich brauchte eine tüte steckt ganz genau
so machen
und auch so messen kann natürlich immer
was gesundes leckeres robert ich glaube
ich bin dem richtigen stand oder
scarione mit stoßen jetzt mal mit
smoothies an
richtig lecker
ihr wisst ja dass ich daheim die
schlechtesten töpfe auf der ganzen welt
wahrscheinlich habe er hatte immer
wieder an meinem ton wenn ich mein herz
an habe dann hört man immer so dieses
summen und ich bin jetzt hier natürlich
auch der messe weil ich eigentlich auch
gute köpfe haben will
und hier gibt es echt tausende
hersteller jetzt bin ich hier einfach
mal an dem stand weil ich hier die
schönen tag für gesehen habe und ich
schaue mich jetzt einfach mal um und
probiere jetzt köpfe aus und schaut dass
ich endlich ruhe töpfer daheim ab und
vielleicht sieht dann auch direkt mit
dem job aufnehmen wenn natürlich auch
eine gute idee
stefan stelle anbieten entweder chocri
tat oder käse
die kulturarbeit ok allesklar.com
ersetzung zum essen gesetz zusammen
gar nicht so lecker aus
pro monat
habil
dankeschön ich bin mir jetzt hier zum
abschluss noch einen türkischen kaffee
einfach noch mal um richtig wach zu
werden denn für mich geht es hier gleich
noch ein bisschen weiter ich schaue mich
noch ein bisschen um aber ihr das gerne
schon mal abschalten ich glaube ich habe
euch schon so ein bisschen oder nicht
nur 14 ich habe viele eindrücke gegeben
wie sie auf der messe zugeht was es hier
alles gibt wenn heute zusammen leider
nur zwei hallen geschafft aber ich bin
noch daran alle elf zu schaffen und ich
würde mal sagen ich genieße das jetzt
einfach karima krieg gleich von kaffee
morath kriegt den kaffee und ihr könnt
einfach entspannen letzten runden zu tun
alle kann